interestingly we're not going to talk
about a version of the prototype or
pattern that does not involve shared
methods when we were talking about
decorators and when we were talking
about the functional class pattern we
examined the technique of using shared
methods or using methods that were
defined in line in the body of the
constructor but the prototypal pattern
really does not lend itself well to the
same examination why do you think that
might be as I see it function sharing
via a prototype delegation is the very
goal of the prototype pattern if methods
were defined inside the constructor
there really wouldn't be any reason to
delegate the instances to any prototype
at all and that's it for prototyping
classes with all of this background
information behind us it's going to be
very easy to understand the
pseudo-classical pattern